what started as a few steps about six
months ago has turned into walking
swimming and biking today with the help
of ai software the technology uses
electrodes to send personalized signals
to spinal nerves which control leg and
trunk movements
so much more precise technology
which allowed us to
target individuals with the most severe
form of spinal cord injury
clinically complete spinal cord injury
no sensation no movement and yet with
this technology they've been able to
take independent steps although outside
the laboratory scientists repurposed a
spinal cord stimulator so instead of
stimulating nerves through the back of
the spine which works for managing
chronic pain signals reach the spine
through a person's sides this allows for
very specific targeting
with this new technology that we have
developed our electrodes are more
lateral so we can access kind of a cable
that enter the spinal cord a different
location and this way we can be very
specific in the different regions of the
spinal cord that we activate findings
published in the journal nature medicine
show this electrode system works faster
than previous attempts at electrically
stimulating the spinal cord
the software that runs the device is
also tailored to each person's anatomy
to target the specific spots you need to
understand where they are
so for that
we modelize the spinal cords and we
understand exactly where the anatomy of
these different spots are
and then we design the stimulation
following the anatomy of each person
stimulation program
it's not a perfect system though
scientists say while they've regained
the ability to do things like walking or
cycling the patients did not regain
natural movements
but block says it takes time
and the more they train the more they
start building muscles and the more
fluid it becomes and they understand
what they have to do and they learn to
work with this technology
it's immediate the movement is immediate
but you ha you need to to understand how
it goes to be better and better and your
body is also getting used to it curtin
says they plan to launch a trial in
about a year involving 70 to 100
patients primarily in the united states
if the early findings are confirmed by
larger studies researchers say it could
lead to those with spinal cord injuries
being able to regain movement with just
a single command using a phone or smart
watch
sean previl global news